Even by the standards of superhero comics,
Supergirl's long history is truly weird.
From her ill-fated romances to being obliterated
from existence and replaced by a blob of protoplasm
that used to sleep with Lex Luthor, here are
the most unbelievably bizarre pieces of Supergirl's
buck wild history.
The single weirdest thing about Supergirl
might be that she didn't show up for a full
20 years after the creation of Superman.
Despite introducing Superboy in 1944 and Krypto
the Superdog in 1955, DC Comics wouldn't get
around to even attempting Supergirl for another
three years after that.
When they finally did get around to this whole
"Super-Girl" thing, she was originally introduced
as a one-off character.
Not only was this version not Superman's cousin,
she actually died at the end of the story,
and was never seen again.
The first version, the one with the hyphen
in her name, showed up in 1958's Superman
#123, when Superman's Pal Jimmy Olsen found
a magic genie belt and wished her into existence.
After a few encounters in which she and Superman
kept getting in each other's way, Super-Girl
wound up exposing herself to Kryptonite and
then begging Jimmy to end her hellish existence.
Pretty dark.
Despite her unfortunate end, this Super-Girl
served as a prototype for the Girl of Steel
that would be introduced the following year
after readers responded well to the idea.
Like Super-Girl, Kara's relative inexperience
with her powers would be a frequent plot point,
and visually, they were almost indistinguishable.
Super-Girl's costume was not only similar
to what readers would see, it's virtually
identical to the one Melissa Benoist would
wear on the Supergirl TV show almost 60 years
later.
In 1959, Action Comics #252 told the story
of "The Supergirl From Krypton," and introduced
readers to Supergirl for real.
This time, it was Kara Zor-El, Superman's
cousin whose family had survived the destruction
of Krypton when their home, Argo City, was
blasted into space as a single intact chunk
of the planet.
Unfortunately, the explosion turned Argo City
into Kryptonite, poisoning the inhabitants
and leading Zor-El to follow in his brother's
footsteps by packing his kid into a rocket
and shooting her to Earth.
All things considered, that's a pretty plausible
origin story by Superman standards.
The weirdest part of the story is that Kara
gets a pretty cold reception from her cousin.
For two decades' worth of stories, Superman
had believed himself to be the only survivor
of his home planet, alone in the universe.
Finally, he has a connection to Krypton, someone
else who has lost her entire family and culture.
At first, he's welcoming... and then she asks
if she can come live with him.
Superman's response is to refuse on the basis
of his secret identity being in jeopardy.
In other words, he doesn't want her cramping
his style at his bachelor pad.
Instead, he gives her a wig and drops her
off at an orphanage.
That's how Superman deals with his only living
relative in the universe.
By and large, Supergirl's adventures in the
'50s and '60s tended to follow the same pattern
as Superman's, at least at first.
Her first major love interest was Dick Malverne,
a classmate who, like Lois Lane and Lana Lang
before him, suspected Kara's secret identity
and tried to trick her into revealing herself.
As time went on, though, Supergirl's love
life got truly weird.
In addition to a long-running romance with
a cyborg from the future, Supergirl's primary
romantic interest was a horse.
Specifically, Comet the Super-Horse.
Just wait, it gets crazier.
Comet had actually been a centaur back in
Hercules' time who, through a combination
of curses and bizarre events, wound up living
in space for a couple thousand years as a
bulletproof flying horse who still had sentience.
Whenever a specific comet came close to Earth,
though, the magic would turn him fully human
for a few days.
So naturally, he kept all of this secret from
Supergirl, assumed the human identity of ace
rodeo rider "Bronco" Bill Starr, and dated
Supergirl without ever telling her who he
was.
No romantic relationship in comics has ever
even gotten close to being that weird.
As you might've heard, 1979 saw the release
of Superman: The Movie, which was kind of
a big deal.
With Christopher Reeve's performance as the
Man of Steel, audiences loved the movie, which
launched DC's flagship character into a full-on
franchise.
By the mid-'80s and the release of Superman
III, enthusiasm for the Superman films had
waned a bit, but they were still successful
enough to warrant a spinoff.
Thus Supergirl, which attempted to recapture
the magic and expand Superman's movie universe
and didn't quite manage to pull it off.
While Helen Slater received a fair amount
of praise in the title role, the movie itself
was pretty weird.
For one thing, it had very little connection
to the other Superman films.
The only actor to appear in both was Marc
McClure as Jimmy Olsen, without even a cameo
from Reeve.
Even stranger was the plot.
The film pitted Supergirl against Faye Dunaway
as an aspiring witch named Selena who gets
her hands on a Kryptonian artifact called
the "Omegahedron" and tries to use it to summon
demons.
Still, Slater's wide-eyed earnestness in the
part has its appeal, and her connection to
the character has remained strong throughout
the decades since Slater would go on to play
Superman's mother, Lara, on Smallville, Supergirl's
adopted mom Eliza Danvers on Supergirl, and
even voiced Superman's mom, Martha Kent, in
an animated film.
In 1986, DC Comics launched an ambitious attempt
to restructure their entire universe with
a yearlong event called Crisis on Infinite
Earths.
The main idea was to eliminate some of the
aspects that readers had come to regard as
hokey and overcomplicated, condensing confusing
timelines down to a single, streamlined universe.
Given that he had a longer and more convoluted
history than anyone else on the DC Comics
roster, it's not surprising that the Superman
books went through the biggest overhaul.
Along with recasting Lex Luthor as a deeply
corrupt billionaire businessman, the big changes
came in the form of a new origin for Clark
Kent that re-established him as the true Last
Son of Krypton.
In the new continuity, he was now the only
survivor of the planet's explosion and eliminated
the idea that he had his full powers before
he was an adult.
That meant no Superboy, no Krypto the Superdog,
no Comet the Super-Horse, and no Supergirl.
To give the character an ending rather than
just writing her out of the books, Crisis
on Infinite Earths saw Kara sacrificing her
life in order to save Superman and, with him,
countless billions of innocent lives.
The thing is, the way the effects of Crisis
were resolved in the books, she wasn't a dead
hero who was remembered in honor.
Instead, in the new DC Universe, she'd simply
never existed.
There was, however, an epilogue to Kara's
story that cropped up in a pretty unexpected
place.
In 1989's Christmas with the Superheroes,
a holiday anthology with a handful of stories,
the ghostly Deadman lamented the fact that
while he could briefly possess the living,
he'd always leave them with no memory of his
heroic deeds.
While he dealt with those feelings, a ghostly
woman showed up and told him that heroism
isn't done for recognition.
In the final panels of the story, the woman
gives her name as Kara, and while it didn't
mean anything to Deadman, it meant a lot to
the readers.
Crisis had done its level best to get rid
of concepts like Superboy, Supergirl, and
Krypto, but if you're familiar with superhero
stories at all, it probably won't surprise
you to learn that literally all of it eventually
came back.
Even putting aside the nostalgia that a new
generation of creators had for their favorites,
copyrights on characters like Supergirl are
very valuable, and if they're not being used,
they can fall out of the control of the companies
that own them.
Supergirl's return to the comics page isn't
surprising.
The fact that she did it in less than two
years, however, is pretty surprising.
To be fair, this wasn't Kara Zor-El.
Instead, this Supergirl was a shape-shifting
"protoplasmic matrix" created in an alternate
pocket dimension by a morally good Lex Luthor,
who made her look like his dead ex-girlfriend
and gave her all of Superman's powers plus
turning invisible.
She then came to the regular DC Earth and
moved in with Superman's parents, who called
her "Mae," short for "Matrix," and she became
the new Supergirl.
"Woah."
She then moved in with Lex Luthor II, who
was actually the regular, evil Lex Luthor
who had transplanted his brain into a clone
body and told everyone that he was his own
son.
A few years later, she symbiotically bonded
with a dead teenager and split into a good
Matrix and an evil Matrix, and might have
also been an angel.
Good thing we had that Crisis thing, huh?
This new stuff was way easier for new readers
to understand than "she's Superman's cousin."
If you think the post-Crisis Supergirl was
complicated, get ready, because we're about
to talk about Power Girl.
Right from the start, she's a little more
complicated, but the short version is that
before Crisis, DC's multiverse contained a
dimension called Earth-2 where they stuck
all the characters from the '40s who had been
rebooted in the '50s and '60s.
Whenever they showed up, they were always
presented as being a decade or two older than
their mainstream "Earth-1" counterparts, giving
a home to characters like the original Flash,
Green Lantern, and Superman.
Superman still had a cousin on that Earth,
but Earth-2's Kara Zor-L didn't go by Supergirl.
Instead, this older version went by Power
Girl, with a completely different costume.
For some reason, Power Girl was considered
to be more necessary for the post-Crisis DC
Universe, and managed to stick around once
the universe was streamlined.
The thing is, Power Girl was an alternate
version of a character who no longer existed,
from a universe that no longer existed, whose
entire reason for being had been completely
eliminated.
The post-Crisis Power Girl could no longer
be Superman's cousin, and creators spent the
next 20 years trying to figure out what her
deal was.
The first big solution was that she was actually
the granddaughter of a wizard from the lost
continent of Atlantis who put her in a magic
crystal for 45,000 years.
Then she got pregnant and gave birth to a
magic rapidly-aging baby who was never seen
again.
Then she was a major character in a team book
that, when it got canceled, was revealed to
have been a fantasy drawn in a child's coloring
book.
Then she was just Superman's cousin again.
Simple!
"I missed out on the whole thing to be honest
with you.
I was confused by it.
I was confused by the whole thing, if if I were
being honest.”
If the concept of Matrix-Supergirl wasn't
weird enough, 1996 saw the launch of a new
Supergirl series, in which Supergirl gained
a new secret identity.
This time, it was Linda Danvers, a young woman
who had unfortunately been kidnapped and sacrificed
to the devil before her first comic ever even
started.
Matrix found her body and, overwhelmed with
grief, bonded with her, merging her protoplasmic
form and personality with Linda's, becoming
a new Supergirl in the process.
A little ways into the run, Supergirl spontaneously
developed the ability to sprout fiery wings,
and the book began to feature Wallace Johnson,
a.k.a. Wally the God-Boy, a boy who claimed
he was God.
It eventually turned out that Linda was an
"Earth-born angel," and that bonding with
Matrix's super-powered protoplasm had allowed
her human form to contain this divine essence.
At this point, Supergirl was an angel who
was also a teenage devil worshipper who was
also a blob from another dimension, who was
also somehow still connected to Superman.
It won't surprise you to learn that after
a few years of this, they got rid of this
Supergirl and introduced another one who was
just Superman's cousin from Krypton.
"Her name is Kara Zor-El, from Krypton.
She's my cousin."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.